do you think of us humans as individuals
that are like born and die or is it are
we just all part of one living organism
that is
earth that is nature
I don't think there's a clear line there
I think it's all kind of just fuzzy I
don't know I mean I don't think I'm
conscious I don't think I'm anything I
think I'm just a computer program
so it's all computation but I think
running in your head is just a is a this
computation everything running in the
universe is computation I think I
believe the extended Church starting
thesis
yeah but if there seems to be an
embodiment to your particular
computation like there's a consistency
well yeah but I mean models have
consistency too
yeah models that have been rlh after
will continually say you know like well
how do I murder ethnic minorities oh
well I can't let you do that Al there's
a consistency to that behavior
it's all rlhf
like we all our lhf each other we we
find we uh provide human feedback and in
there that
thereby fine-tune these little pockets
of computation but it's still unclear
why that pocket of computation stays
with you like for years it just kind of
fall like you have this consistent
set of physics biology
uh what like whatever you call the the
neurons firing the electrical centers
the mechanical signals all of that that
seems to stay there and it contains
information it stores information and
that information permeates Through Time
and stays with you there's like memory
it's like sticky okay to be fair like a
lot of the models we're building today
are very even rlhf is nowhere near as
complex as the human loss function
reinforcement learning with human
feedback
um you know when I talked about will GPT
12 be AGI my answer is no of course not
I mean cross-entry loss is never going
to get you there you need
uh probably rln fancy environments in
order to get something that would be
considered like AGI like
so to ask like the question about like
why I don't know like it's just some
Quirk of evolution right I don't think
there's anything particularly special
about
where I ended up
where humans ended up so okay we have
human level intelligence would you call
that AGI whatever we have gi look I
actually I don't really even like the
word AGI um but general intelligence is
defined to be whatever humans have